[Music]
where's a story that's received almost
no media attention but it is a pending
American Society it has been less than a
year and a half since Donald Trump got
elected but the Democratic Party has
changed pretty dramatically just six
years ago for example during this 2012
State of the Union President Obama said
this about immigration watch I believe
as strongly as ever that we should take
on illegal immigration that's why my
administration has put more boots on the
border than ever before that's why there
are fewer illegal crossings than when I
took office
well that's unimaginable today Obama
could not say that and would not say
that instead prominent Democrats are now
calling for the abolition of federal
immigration enforcement the Nation
magazine described Isis quote an
unaccountable strike force executing a
campaign of ethnic cleansing the state
of California is threatening law
enforcement officers there with the rest
if they cooperate with ice even
apprehend criminals impoverished
Democratic cities like Baltimore have
set aside tax dollars to help you
illegal immigrants fight deportation how
long before the National Party calls her
giving illegal immigrants the right to
vote that's actually happening in some
towns in Maryland already yesterday on
this show we interviewed an immigration
activist who said that foreign nationals
ought to be able to vote anywhere in the
country they used to be a fringe
position it's not anymore
on the Second Amendment meanwhile the
Democratic Party has moved to advocating
for gun control it's been going on for a
long time to pushing for government gun
confiscation that's a big change just
two years ago here was Hillary Clinton's
position on firearms I'm not looking to
repeal the Second Amendment I'm not
looking to take people's guns away but I
am looking for more support for the
reasonable efforts that need to be
undertaken to keep guns out of the wrong
hands well those words could have been
uttered at any time in the last 30 years
but that was then
Democrats have just spent the last month
openly calling for gun confiscation
Australia's stout gun confiscation and
then just yesterday former Supreme Court
Justice John Paul Stevens demanded the
repeal of the Second Amendment others
have followed that would have been
unthinkable as too few years ago and
then on the subject of abortion in the
1990s you often heard Bill and Hillary
Clinton say abortion ought to be quote
safe legal and rare as recently as 2009
Barack Obama agreed with
watch so let us work together to reduce
the number of women seeking abortions
let's reduce unintended pregnancy let's
let's make adoption more available let's
provide care and support for women who
do carry their children to turn that was
the position of the Democratic Party
really from roe v-- wade until about
yesterday that even though abortion
should remain legal it was undesirable
it was something sad something to be
avoided if possible that's how most
voters feel about it Democrats no longer
say that the party's base is for
abortion be proud of having won
progressives want women to shout shout
your abortion just two days ago Planned
Parenthood in Colorado demanded a new
Disney Princess one who's had an
abortion to be a role model for girls
these are views outside the mainstream
is measured by opinion polling are they
the topics are the issues that Democrats
are going to run on during the midterm
elections joining us tonight is someone
who has spent a long time in the
Democratic Party Jennifer Palmieri she's
spent years at the heart of it she was
communications director for both the
Obama White House and the Hillary
Clinton presidential campaign she got a
brand new book out which is doing very
well on Amazon it's called dear Madam
President and she joins the same jump
over a thanks for a month I'm happy to
be here so a lot has been written about
the changes in the Republican Party
under Trump it's changed a lot there's
no doubt about that
right the Democratic Party has changed I
would say as much or more and it's
gotten very little attention do you
acknowledge that President Obama going
out and saying I'm gonna crack down on
illegal immigration couldn't say that
today no because what's happened is the
problem got a lot worse in Congress
wouldn't do anything about it
you know when President Obama gave that
speech many years ago that was when we
were trying to pass comprehensive
immigration reform and you tried to past
it and you got it through one body and
you couldn't get it through the other
and Congress is broken and it won't pass
it and so the the problem has gotten a
lot worse in the meantime but like well
that's true really what was that what
are you talking about the demmer
democrats are in
the main stream of views when it comes
to guns and when it comes to immigration
okay and when it comes to a boil then
let me ask you and there's no one that
thinks that abortion shouldn't be safe
legal and rare and I guess this is the
part of the show where you set me up
with extreme strong questions then are
there any circumstances when
non-citizens should be allowed to vote
no I think that that it's citizenship
voting comes with citizenship but that
is but but should not citizen should
never vote in a way American election
but what's happened is that is despite
Paulette you know the Congress is broken
it does not react to what the people
want I agree with that completely what
immigration reform that people want more
gun control okay that is what they
should but the details matter so you
said that non-citizens should never vote
in elections I argue that your party
will overtake you in that question soon
but we'll see
well it's bet you know maybe if Congress
never does anything to address
immigration oh then more than
non-citizens should vote this is the
part where I'm asking you what you are
Tucker you know what I so I said I got
the invitation to come on your show and
I'm immediately I was like there's no
way I'm doing that and then I thought I
like Tucker and he's a smart guy but I'm
actually I you sure I am a woman with
nothing to lose so I was like sure I'm
gonna go on if you think you really
lucky Tucker you really believe that the
Democratic Party thinks that abortion
shouldn't be rare let me ask you this
hold on I'll gets that but do you think
the government should ever take guns
from law-abiding people that's not a
trick question it's a sincere question I
think that there should be an assault
weapons ban I don't think that people
need to take their guns away I think
there should be an assault with people
who own the gun you were setting the
conversation up to purposefully put me
in a box yes you don't need to that what
don't we use your episode I think
everyone watching liberals and
conservatives would acknowledge that's a
totally fair question why isn't it not
question cuz you don't want to answer it
I don't know because because it is not
it's not a sincere question it was very
much easier I can promise you I couldn't
tell you how so serious husband has a
number of guns too that's great but even
if I didn't should government ever take
the guns of people who have not misused
them I think we've addressed and you
don't think it should've on you don't
think it should I don't want to answer
your list of questions that are designed
to set me up if you think that's the
setup it tells you how sad our national
conversation has become because my
questions are totally sincere they're
right to the heart of the matter
Orson's I think that's sincere question
would be when it came to guns Wow we
have do you know why people are taking
to the streets do you know why people
are going for all like gun gun reform
but because children are dying in
schools at I understand outrageous uber
so